bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
pour un nouveau numéro de c'est normand
nous sommes à avranches dans la manche
à l'heure du numérique et du mp3 vous
allez découvrir une entreprise leader
mondial dans la fabrication de bandes
sonores analogique l'entreprise mullan
industrie
dans cette usine
le vintage est omniprésent des machines
au produit fini bien loin de l'univers
aseptisé du numérique
chaque année 80 mille kilomètres de
bobines analogiques dédiées à
l'enregistrement sonore sont fabriqués
soit deux fois le tour de la terre
première étape top secrète la
préparation de la formule chimique
une fois l'un des composants pesé
direction la salle des cuves pour être
mélangé avec du solvant un lieu défense
d'entrée notre caméra pourrait
déclencher une réaction explosive
une fois élaboré l'enduit et étalés sur
des films plastiques pour maîtriser
cette fabrication
il faut plusieurs mois de formation
c'est très difficile de trouver des
opérateurs qui qui savent conduire ces
machines parce qu'elles sont ici
plusieurs qualités et plusieurs
compétences pour ali en même temps la
chimie la technique et la mécanique sur
ce marché mullan industries numéro un
mondial avec 75% de la production
internationale ses plus grands clients
les studios de cinéma américains séduit
par la haute définition et la durée de
conservation autre acheteur prestigieux
la nasa l'agencé spatiale américaine des
états majors à travers la planète ou des
laboratoires scientifiques
vous avez devant fait aujourd'hui qu'ils
écoutent des sons dans les fonds marins
dans l'espace
ils ont besoin d'un support de très
haute qualité pour écouter ses sons et
capter des sons même que vous et moi on
est incapable d'écouter pour enregistrer
ces signaux indétectable à l'oreille
humaine immortaliser la bande originale
d'un film pour des clients exigeants pas
le droit à l'erreur fondamentale le
contrôle qualité avec pour la plupart
des machines du 20e siècle
dernier test dans ce laboratoire digne
des films d'espionnage sur ce magnéto
cette bande sera envoyé à un service des
coûts d'une des plus grande armée au
monde
destination finale confidentielles sur
ses lecteurs une bande pour
l'enregistrement d'un album studio
londonien
et pour tester ces bandes sont pas
guitare électrique pas de batterie une
machine beaucoup moins rock'n'roll
guillaume rock'n'roll donc on va
utiliser un générateur de signaux donc
on va envoyer un signal une tonalité
donc dans cette tête là qui va
enregistrer signal sur la bande et cette
tête suivante va récupérer signal et on
va analyser et comparer les deux signaux
entrants et sortants de pour voir si
c'est aussi nette aussi pur aussi bon
ces leçons saint-prime bien enfin voilà
exactement la production et la vente de
bandes analogiques ont connu cette année
une croissance de 20% conséquences sur
l'emploi dans l'entreprise
cinq personnes embauchées en cdi et 2 en
intérim pour gagner de nouveaux marchés
et conquérir de nouveaux clients mullan
industrie sera présent la fin de ce mois
au grand salon international des
professionnels du son à los angeles dans
la silicon valley à très bientôt sur
france 3 pour un prochain c'est normand